bob
are you an amish country
what are you in amish country
amish country why would you say that i'm
in florida no man the beard because i
was watching this uh youtube series and
this guy went to amish country and they
have a very similar beard oh with the
with the mustache yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
i just cut it today okay
all right so you've got a disrespectful
wife so what's happening
so i'm 27 now i was 25 when i was dating
her um and one thing that i noticed now
that i'm red pilled
um which was i i found your content
after i got married which was a year and
a half ago
um
was like we were at a date and i told
her well i uh i love wearing my trump
hat out in public i just think it was
the you know make america great or keep
america great you know trump 2020 hat
yeah so um she's like oh well you can't
wear that when we're going out in public
together
i was like well that's my first
amendment right like that's too bad
she's like no but that i i you can't
you you can't do that and i think
i went with it at first and then i had
my doubts i was like is she gonna keep
on talking to me like this
and then
i mean recently we've been having
arguments over stupid stuff have you
read my book
i've listened to almo or i've watched
almost all of your videos
okay so
i mean i've probably mentioned it in a
video before but men go through beta
tization through a thousand concessions
so that's an example of one concession
there right it's like i like my trump
hat she doesn't like your trump hat she
tells you to stop wearing the trump hat
so you go okay
right and then you comply so that so
that would be one concession so this is
an example for those of you that are
watching of what one concession looks
like in beta tization through a thousand
concessions so
i'm willing to bet since she said she's
disrespectful she's done this more than
once
well what we've i mean recently we've
been having like stupid arguments i mean
yeah like like now i have the let's go
brandon hat so she won't allow let me to
work you know wear that in public or
even when i'm out mowing the lawn
because she's like oh i don't want our
neighbors to see that that you're
that you haven't let's go brandon with
fjb on the side
and
like recently it's just been stupid
stuff like tonight it was the toilet
seat like she was like you have to put
the toilet seat down after you use the
toilet
and i'm like okay look i value it i know
girls are
like
they're like that whatever
i was speaking to someone else who was
like in my in a similar position to me
he's like yeah dude like married men go
through this with the toilet seat i was
like okay like she's been asking me for
the past year and a half about the
toilet seat i told her look
i i can't like
remember every time i go to the bathroom
in any ways i work okay okay okay i got
some questions for you because like yeah
because i think i understand where
you're at so you're 27 now
i'm 27. and how old is she uh 26. okay
what do you do for a living
um i'm in uh i'm in the aerospace
industry okay and what does the misses
do
uh she's a teacher
shocking yeah i i i feel like she talks
down to me as a teacher and i'll be
honest like even once i mentioned her
like oh there's
i was doing research like do all
marriages suck and then i uh i'll tell
you what the problem is bob is that is
that yes you're unplugged but you're
still a beta
and
and every day every week every year that
goes by
she's better tizing you further so you
see the code in the matrix you know what
she's doing
you know you understand the concept but
you allow it to happen so you're still
kind of oh so so i've i've living in the
matrix
so so i i've been standing up recently
like okay and how's that working out for
you
basically i'll say like
like for the toilet seat i was like look
like i want to meet your need i can't
promise you and then she like got really
really frustrated and
like
and it's not even with the toilet seat
but with other things it's like one to
two minutes discussing something
and then it's like
name calling and i'm like no you're not
gonna i'm not gonna let you call me that
name that's that's [ __ ] like you
cannot call me stupid you can't start
cussing at me like i'm not i'm not gonna
stand up and then she just storms off
and slams the door
so
one of the things that you gotta
understand about teachers is they spend
their days dealing with small children
that they get to boss around
yeah um usually if they deal with
smaller kids like kindergarten grade one
you know uh it's a lot different yeah
that's that's where she is also so
if it's younger kids like she's
basically hurting cats
and she thinks that they're incompetent
you know they're incapable
they're small
she communicates to me right so
you know so so she's looking at you the
same way like she's looking at you like
her her kid right and when that happens
intimacy drops
if not completely off the table but
definitely drops you know to well below
levels that you experience pre-marriage
with all the crazy monkey sex hanging
from the chandeliers and stuff like that
right so that starts to go away then she
better ties you then she starts to take
away some of your rights and privileges
like when you want to wear a hat and you
know what kind of shirt you want to wear
when you're cutting the lawn
oh we had this other discussion about we
wanted to go to a certain event and she
wanted me to wear a white button-down
shirt and i wanted to wear this polo
this is like a short sleeve polo right
it's in florida it's hot and everything
i wanted to wear the polo and she was
she wasn't having it and eventually i
was like you know what i'm just going to
go i'm going to go there by myself like
like this is a nice shirt like like like
the white button down is nice but like
that's a funny story when
when my ex through
um
the engagement party um it was in july
it was hot as hell like humid as hell
and um she's like what are you gonna
wear i'm like i'm gonna wear the shirt
and these shorts and these sandals well
you can't wear shorts why not
because i said so it's you know because
every single wear and pants sort of
thing i was like it's like 40 degrees
and humid i'm wearing shorts i showed up
in shorts i was the only person there in
shorts i do as i please
right
like women will [ __ ] test you for your
competency you know to make sure that
she feels like she's the best that she
can get
and
you've already failed a bunch of those
[ __ ] tests
and she's already better ties you so now
she has this condition in her mind like
well i can talk to bob like this you
know i can call him stupid or i can you
know tell him tell him off or not
putting the toilet seat in the right
direction for
for me as it serves me so
to be to be honest with you something
like this to try to fix it is very hard
i don't even i don't even want to get
involved right i mean like look
if you want to book me privately and
we'll do a couple hours of coaching i'm
expensive right yeah i don't have like
many people we have a counselor here
that we go to for counseling okay well
that like clearly this marriage is not
working out right and you might be
red-pilled but if you think that this is
gonna work out with some other check
you're still red pill beta oh i'm not
getting married again like screw that
like dating you know dating you know
maybe you invite her in you get a dog
together sort of thing you know maybe
you change your mind five ten years down
the road if you're still the same guy
right now just like the last one better
ties you because you couldn't stand up
for yourself and say
what's wrong with you putting the toilet
seat down you know the direction that
you want
what are you bothering with me with this
she says it's this it's it's disgusting
and nasty when she walks in and sees the
toilet seat off yeah well when you guys
were dating did she give you a hard time
about the toilet seat
um right so why the [ __ ] is it a problem
now
i mean she asked me like towards the
beginning of our marriage and like i
tried to sometimes but yeah but again
when you were dating was a toilet seat a
problem for
oh we we weren't living together when we
were dating it doesn't matter she you
know she came over he went over to her
place right like it wasn't a problem
then right now all of a sudden it's a
problem
you see what i'm saying right i don't
know why it's like why wasn't it a
problem you know for you before and now
it's a problem today
right like i got [ __ ] i got to do like
don't bother me with this and then you
walk away
like that's how an unplugged alpha would
handle it it's not like bicker and
engage in a fight like you don't
you don't play like these silly games
with them right so
basically you got more work to do like
she like she has to be able to look at
you and when you say no she's like okay
but if you say no and she's looking at
you like one of her kids and like you
know you must obey she's gonna persist
you know if she sees you as beneath her
women can't respect the guy unless she
you know can look up to him and right
now she's feeling like she can't look up
to you she's feeling like yeah and
that's why she doesn't respect you and
that's why she talks down you and that's
why she calls you stupid sort of stuff
like that so
the work that you got to do on yourself
is gonna pay dividends
maybe not in this relationship but
probably in the next one to fix
something like this dude it's very hard
it's
it's in my view not worth it
in my view cut ties do you guys have
kids
no kids and she's not pregnant cut ties
get divorced call it a [ __ ] day go do
your teaching job i'm gonna go do my own
thing and leave the toilet up when i
feel like it once you figure yourself
out and you level yourself up you know
you develop yourself as a man you know
become the unplugged alpha sort of thing
right then you'll be in a better
position to make better choices with
women but i mean you've got leveling up
to do for yourself
yeah
so so so i don't want to take too much
of your time but i think like
i'm a pretty like high value man like
good
good
no
i mean i have a good job in the
aerospace industry what did you make
last year
about 90. okay but i mean like you look
like you're from amish country still
right like you don't look like the kind
of guy that you're going to get like i'm
just being honest with you dude like
i've i've seen all the data you're not
looking like the kind of guy that women
are gonna swipe right on
enthusiastically right okay is it the
beard
it's the beard it's a look you don't
look you know very strong and masculine
i'd get some new glasses and frames you
know that you know fit your face better
get some higher index lenses so you
don't get quite the bend in the glass
sort of thing change your style yeah the
shirt kind of sucks
um how tall are you and what do you
weigh
uh five eight i actually got down to 130
i've been doing a lot of exercise okay
so you're pretty lean
yeah like you're super lean like my bmi
is 19 and i've
i do it okay so
you got to throw some muscle on that
frame now broad now you're like look at
me like i'm like i'm close to 50 and i'm
in better shape than you like how is
that possible
i don't know
see what i'm saying right working out
just specific weightlifting just just do
the work right you know put in the reps
uh i would join a dojo learn how to be
lethal right like when you start
fighting and you start punching people
and you start sparring and [ __ ] like
that and you knock a guy in the head
that feels [ __ ] good
okay like it's it's gonna enhance your
confidence right so the next time a
chick tries to tell you off over a
toilet seat or a certain hat that you're
going to wear you're going to be like
shut up i got other options if you don't
like it i'll just call up so and so
right
you see what i'm saying right you know
because you have other options because
you're a stronger height like a lot of
people call themselves high value men
but they're not
like do beautiful women that you want to
be with look at you as a high value guy
do they do they chase you down are they
blowing up your phone saying hey bob
what are you doing this weekend can you
help me out with the
you know
i mean not i'm not not now that i'm
married i haven't you know hey listen
you know women would rather date a
married guy than a guy that lives in his
mom's basement
so
the point that i'm making is that you
know you're calling yourself a certain
value but realistically on the sexual
marketplace when they're looking at you
you're not where you think you are
and you're definitely not where you
think you are because you're getting
shitty results in your marriage i can
always tell what somebody's belief
system looks like by the choices they
make every day and what they'll tolerate
and the results that they get so if you
just reverse engineers of you know from
the top of the funnel results wife's a
[ __ ] she yells at me over the toilet
seat calls me stupid
okay well what choices is bob making
right
what does his belief system look like
that's where the problem is is your
belief system you can start with you're
not a 10 out of 10 bro
sorry you know i like
i'm not trying to disparage you or put
you down i'm just stating facts right
yeah for sure i'm happy to take feedback
yeah
like i want you to do the work like i
want you to come back in a year with
like jack tan and juicy as [ __ ] with a
nice ass beer and be like yo rich you're
right man
all right the thing is she was so she's
like so nice even like
even like just in general texting
like calling just having dinner she's so
nice and then it just comes these
nonsense stuff it's just what my my
girlfriend has never called me stupid
never like not [ __ ] once it would be
the last word out of her mouth if she
called me [ __ ] stupid
like like
ah like like that like high value guys
don't tolerate bossy disagreeable [ __ ]
women over trivial things
so i mean you're saying hey you know
she's a nice person and she texts me and
she's kind and that sort of stuff yeah
teachers are
okay but she's also calling you stupid
and giving you [ __ ] over a toilet seat
basic stuff in life
and you make double the money that she
does
like why aren't you running the
household
oh like i i i think i i do in terms of
you know you don't because she's yelling
at you over the toilet seat bro
well i mean i do want to like validate
like your [ __ ] you can't even cut the
grass wearing the hat that you want
i'm going to try right now the next time
you go outside
wear the shirt that you want wear the
hat that you want yeah but why are you
wearing that i told you it's
embarrassing shut up
you can't talk to me like that i just
did
i'm wearing the hat it's my hat
so so this exact scenario happens and
then she just starts cussing me out and
then slamming doors
dude i'm telling you it's next to
impossible to fix a situation where
you've already been beta tized and then
you try to recl like
i've unplugged i see the code in the
matrix red so i'm red pill blah blah
blah cool but she still sees you as the
same
guy that she shits on before you were
red pilled
yeah right
so
again the work that you need to do on
yourself is going to pay dividends for
you
probably not in this relationship but
most definitely with the next one
because you start
it all begins with frame it all begins
with frame yeah right is she in your
frame or are you in her frame and right
now i can tell you're in her frame
right you think a lot of things she's in
my frame
dude
again i've never been called stupid i
never get lectured over anything
ever
it's nonsense stupid is the least of the
insults the insults matter it's still an
issue not worst like no like she she's
like insulted me with other cuss words
you know sayings and just
i've never said anything like that to
her you get out of life what you
tolerate bob
right so i mean like you know keep keep
doing the marriage counseling [ __ ]
you know keep you know dealing with the
fights
you're going to start to develop a
backbone you're going to not tolerate
things
look um if you want to learn more about
ltr stuff uh i'd probably say find some
of rhinestones uh material go to the red
pill subreddit um you know see what guys
are doing to try to reclaim their
masculinity and you know move from beta
tization to you know alpha credit card
sort of thing
but um
i've not seen it be very successful and
even if you are successful you're still
going to be dealing with the same [ __ ]
that beta ties you
right
i mean like you're still gonna have that
animosity
over the process
yeah and then just one one other thing
like i mentioned to her like i found
your channel
she watched one of your videos and i'm a
misogynist i'm a sexist uh
oh so she said i've got a small pp
she said
she said you over simplify things yeah
okay and then she's like i don't want
you watching his videos anymore and i'm
like
well she's going to be pissed when she
sees this interview she better not i
don't think she's going to
but you guys know that when you come on
my show it's a live show and it's and it
ends up on the internet so
don't come crying to me when she gets
pissed off at you have some balls and
lift up your skirt and say yeah i had
that conversation what are you going to
do about it
and i am going to wear the hat and i'm
going to wear this shirt and i'm not
going to be listening about toilets just
move the [ __ ] seat the amount of time
that it takes you to walk over here and
complain to me about the seat is stupid
you move the seat in the direction that
it needs to be don't bother me with this
[ __ ] again
yeah
right
yeah okay becky
thank you so much
all right bob see you buddy rachel
continue to listen to your program all
right you got it hey guys i really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you